well Deadpool 3 has resumed filming and
we got leaks before it's shut down due
to the strikes and now of course we are
getting leaks after they have resumed
filming since the strikes are now over
things are going full speed ahead with
Deadpool 3 and this movie is supposed to
be what Marvel has the most faith in
right now we'll talk about why in this
video but first let's talk about these
leaks that Ryan Reynolds himself is now
sharing or is he Ryan Reynolds posted a
supposed Deadpool Leak with a fresh new
character on it on Twitter today a
character that is not even from one the
MCU or two the Marvel Fox Universe this
is the photo and as you can see here
it's Predator now Ryan Reynolds is
clearly trolling laughing so hard right
now this picture along with others that
he released are clearly fake and there
is a very specific reason that Ryan
Reynolds has released this photo and
other photos as well but before we
dismiss this I want to talk about the
possibility of this actually happening
and I actually think that this would be
a genius idea if they truly did this and
I believe they are going to do something
like this just not maybe specifically
with predator or maybe they actually are
and it's a double troll by Ryan Reynolds
don't get me wrong this photo is
definitely fake along with the others
but you have to admit it would be very
Ryan Reynolds of him to put Predator
into the movie after pulling the stunt
but right off the that if some of you
are wondering how would this even be
possible how could Predator appear in a
Marvel SL Disney movie well keep in mind
Disney acquired 20th Century Fox who
produced Predator so they own the rights
to Predator they can legally use
predator in the MCU in any Marvel movie
any Disney movie they have the rights to
do this so for some people who are
saying out there this isn't even
possible it is actually and I believe
this could be a reflection and a mockery
of some really amazing scenes that we
could get in Deadpool 3 now I really
think this is an incredibly clever
marketing scheme by Ryan Reynolds and by
Marvel Studios and I do actually think
that they are hinting at a reality of
this being possible maybe not
specifically for predator but for
non-marvel characters to show up in the
MCU in Deadpool 3 now Ryan did this for
a few reasons one is obviously it's very
hilarious to him he's obviously having a
lot of fun with it even on Twitter Hugh
Jackman is commenting on some of the
post that he's been doing some of the
pictures that he's been putting out
there that are clearly fake especially
since Ryan Reynolds came out the other
day talking about the Deadpool 3 leaks
he issued a statement stating basically
hey he knows these leaks are out there
this is what he posted to his story
surprises are part of the magic of
theatrical movies it's important for us
to shoot the new Deadpool film in real
natural environments using practical
effects as opposed to making the movie
indoors and digitally t photo lenses
continue to spoil surprises and create a
difficult situation for everyone here's
hoping some of the websites and social
channels hold back showing images before
they're ready the film is built for
audience joy and our highest hope is to
preserve as much of that magic as
possible for the finished film and the
big screen part of the reason people
post spoilers is because they're excited
I realize these aren't real world issues
and it's firmly in the good problems
bucket I love making this movie and at
the bottom it shows Deadpool wearing a
Santa hat saying ho ho ho and then we
have an animated Wolverine looks like it
could be from one of the old arcade
X-Men games maybe something like Marvel
versus Capcom that's besides the point
the point is Ryan Reynolds has asked
people to not share the leaked photos
now there were some that came out
recently we didn't show them on the
channel we didn't show the cameos on the
channel we showed some Easter eggs and
obviously we're showing Predator because
Ryan Reynolds released this himself and
of course it's fake and I do believe
this is really a big marketing plan look
here's the deal Marvel Studios knows
leaks happen especially when you have to
film outside there are Paparazzi
companies who specifically go out with
their huge telephoto lenses like Ryan
Reynolds mentioned and their sole
purpose is to sneak these photos it's
not illegal it happens and the photos
get out and when Ryan Reynolds released
this fake Deadpool leaked photo today
this is what he said on Twitter Deadpool
began with a leak so I'm joining in but
please don't overuse the phrase
Deadpool leaks because it might screw up
search results if anyone is looking for
Deadpool leaks or Deadpool spoilers or
perhaps Deadpool scoops and below this
in the thread of it what's funny is he
actually posts the leaked photos from
the set of Deadpool 3 that were leaked
but he's photoshopped some stuff in it
with Mickey Mouse and a money bag kind
of again trolling and then he posts
pictures that are straight up just leaks
from the set this is clever really
really clever and obviously this
Predator scene isn't going to happen but
I really think that it should it doesn't
necessarily have to be with Predator
obviously it could be another character
outside of the MCU but I think it would
be very very clever and it would be what
the MCU needs I think if they made this
scene real it would be bloody brilliant
the reason I think it's so brilliant is
because in a true Multiverse if the
Multiverse was real in our lives in our
real lives not in the MCU but our real
lives then literally anything is
possible we've been talking about this a
while on the channel but even as far
back as 2 years ago I've been stating
that it would be really cool if maybe
some DC characters popped up in a
Multiverse film because it's possible
and in a true Multiverse film where
anything can happen and there are
infinite amounts of different universes
some of those universes are going to be
non-marvel related even inside the MCU
that's just how the Multiverse works and
this is brilliant because they are
taking us to one of those non-marvel
related universes or at least bringing a
part of that Universe to our universe
and it's brilliant we'll use predator as
an example because that's obviously who
Ryan Reynolds threw in there so Predator
will come from the Predator Universe
fall into the void which is what we know
this place to be right now then he would
most likely fight Deadpool and Wolverine
which honestly I would really be here
for I think that would be a pretty epic
fight I obviously know that Deadpool and
Wolverine would win obviously
regenerative abilities but still
insanely cool to see nonetheless and
imagine if other characters from other
universes popped up as well imagine if
you saw Deadpool and Wolverine fighting
Predator with the X-Men fighting at the
same time you also have Red Skull there
fighting and then characters from other
universe is not even a part of Marvel
this would be insanely epic to see and
this would truly never have been done
before Marvel Studios has brought
characters together from the same
universe but never different franchises
outside of their own and I think this
could be a part of their plan to use
characters outside of Marvel from Disney
that Disney owns and that the 20th
Century Fox brand owns because Disney
owns them and make it a true Multiverse
film not just an MCU Multiverse film but
an actual Multiverse film obviously not
for the whole movie for one part of it a
couple scenes maybe just one but it
would be epic and this is really why
Marvel Studios has so much faith in this
film because I think it's actually doing
a Multiverse film inside the MCU Justice
and this is why Marvel has faith in it
so how could this scene work a scene
that has characters from other
non-marvel universes coming into it well
basically from what know this area that
Wolverine and Deadpool are in here where
they're fighting and we can see the 20th
Century Fox logo in the background this
seems to be the void and if you've
watched our videos on Deadpool 3 pretty
much in every video we've mentioned how
the TVA is going to go about the
Multiverse and pick heroes from their
universes that are dying to save them to
kind of recruit for a multiversal
Avengers team but we do know that the
Multiverse is going to be collapsing and
there are going to be some remnants left
over from these universes I believe they
will end up here at the void this this
is why if you've seen some of the other
leaked photos we won't mention the
cameos that have been shown but this is
how they could possibly end up there at
the same location as Wolverine and
Deadpool it's the void where remnants of
other universes are left over so it's
really quite easy for them to kind of
put whoever Disney owns and that is a
lot of people between Disney Marvel and
all of the fox franchises in this scene
especially if they are indeed going to
kill the so-called Fox Universe they
could really have anybody from any Fox
Universe show up in the void here and
Wolverine and Deadpool could fight him
and kill him I think it would be an epic
idea and I do think we see something
along those lines I do think we see a
non-marvel character in here just
because it's Deadpool he breaks the
fourth wall and it's clever and I think
Ryan Reynolds has thought of this and
honestly Ryan's brilliant this is super
clever I'm sure he's getting a great
laugh out of this I did as well but let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and let me know if
you're one of those people who enjoy
seeing the leaks beforehand or not don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can enter our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series x a PS5
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Twitter and Instagram as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof